اعترف الجيش الإسرائيلي اليوم
بأنهم دخلوا مقبرة وأخرجوا
الجثث من القبور كجزء مما
يقولون إنه بحث عن
رفات الرهائن الإسرائيليين، ولكن عندما
أصدر الجيش الإسرائيلي هذا البيان، فإننا
نكمل تحقيقنا في
تدنيس الجيش الإسرائيلي
للمقابر.  وما وجدناه هو 16
مقبرة في أنحاء غزة متضررة أو
مدمرة. أريد أن أحذر مشاهدينا
من أنهم قد يجدون بعض هذه الصور
مزعجة في غزة، حتى الموتى لا يستطيعون
الهروب من مهانات
الحرب. تم تدنيس أكثر من اثنتي عشرة مقبرة مثل
هذه في جباليا  من قبل
الجيش الإسرائيلي، دمرت شواهد القبور
التربة وعلامات الدوس المقلوبة ولم
يتبق سوى القليل للأحياء لتكريم
موتاهم، وهذه هي نفس المقبرة قبل
الحرب وبعد شهر واحد،
يمكن رؤية سلسلة من العلامات على
الحافة الشمالية الغربية، وهي ليست استثناءً من
تحليل CNN لمقاطع الفيديو  ووجدت صور الأقمار الصناعية
أن 16 مقبرة قد
تضررت أو دمرت على يد
الجيش الإسرائيلي منذ أن شن
هجومه البري بينما توغلت القوات الإسرائيلية في عمق
غزة، وسحقت قبور
آلاف الفلسطينيين بين
نوفمبر/تشرين الثاني ويناير/كانون الثاني جانينا ديل
المديرة المشاركة لمعهد جامعة أكسفورد
بالنسبة لقانون الأخلاق والنزاعات المسلحة،
يقول إن تدمير المقابر
ينتهك القانون الدولي إلا
في ظروف محدودة للغاية،
فالمقابر ليست أهدافًا عسكرية، بل
هي في الواقع ما يعتبره القانون الدولي
شيئًا
مخصصًا عادةً للأغراض المدنية
مثل أماكن العبادة بشكل عام، لذلك هذا
هو  محمية من أي هجوم متعمد، لا
يمكن مهاجمتها أو
تدميرها عمدًا إلا إذا أصبحت
هدفًا عسكريًا في بعض الحالات مثل هذه
المقبرة في مخيم اللاجئين الشيعة، حيث
تحول الجرافات الإسرائيلية المقابر إلى
مواقع عسكرية تقف
المركبات المدرعة خلف أنظمة بناء المباني التي تم رفعها حديثًا،
غالبًا ما يكون الضرر متعمدًا
وتقدميًا  على مدار أسبوعين في شهر ديسمبر/كانون الأول، قام
الجيش بتجريف المزيد والمزيد من
هذه المقبرة الواقعة شرق هان يوناس وبناء
التحصينات الدفاعية. وشهدت شبكة "سي إن إن" عن كثب
نتائج تجريف إسرائيل
للمقابر أثناء تواجدها مع
القوات الإسرائيلية الأسبوع الماضي، حيث كانت ناقلة الجنود المدرعة "سي
إن إن" تسافر
عبر هذا المكان.  مقبرة في ألبر على
طريق ترابي تم تجريفه حديثًا ثم هناك هذه المقابر التي تم فتحها
في مقبرة في حونيس هذا الأسبوع تم
إخراج الجثث من قبورهم في بيان
اعترف الجيش الإسرائيلي
باستخراج الجثث من المقبرة كجزء
من بحثه عن جثث
الرهائن الإسرائيليين  ولم يتمكن متحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي من
تفسير الأضرار التي لحقت
بالمقابر الـ 16 التي حددتها سي إن إن، لكنه قال
إنه في بعض الحالات لا يوجد
خيار آخر لتقديم هذه الصورة لما
يقول إنها منصة إطلاق صواريخ تابعة لحماس في
مقبرة في غزة. ولم تتمكن سي إن إن من
التحقق بشكل مستقل من مكان وجودها.  يبدو أن
المتحدث لم يتمكن من تفسير
الموقع العسكري فوق المقابر، لكنه قال إن
لدينا التزامًا جديًا
باحترام الموتى ولا توجد
سياسة لإنشاء مواقع عسكرية خارج
المقابر في حالة واحدة على الأقل
يبدو أن الجيش الإسرائيلي قد اتبعها.  بذلت
جهودًا حثيثة للمناورة حول مقبرة
مقبرة حرب دار البلح التي تحتوي على
رفات العديد من الجنود المسيحيين واليهود
من الحرب العالمية الأولى، وقد تركت سليمة
على الرغم من الدمار الذي لحق
بمقبرة الطاء، وهي
صورة مختلفة تمامًا يقول السكان إن الجثث
اقتلعتها الجرافات الإسرائيلية
جنوبًا  استشهدت أفريقيا بتدمير إسرائيل
للمقابر كجزء من قضيتها
التي تقول إن إسرائيل ترتكب إبادة جماعية في
غزة، وتنفي إسرائيل هذا الادعاء، لكن
الخبراء يقولون إن تدمير المقابر يمكن أن
يكون دليلا على نية إسرائيل. هناك
معنى رمزي كبير لفكرة أنه
حتى الموتى لم يتركوا في سلام.
يوحي بأن عدم الاحترام تجاه
نوع الحياة الروحية لعدوك
وممتلكاتهم الثقافية في التراث، إنه
دليل على وجود عداء ضد عدوك
وهذا غير مفيد في هذا السياق،
لا يزال الجيش الإسرائيلي
يدنس القبور في
غزة في مقبرة حانون حيث
حفر الجيش  الجثث هذا الأسبوع
الضرر واسع النطاق
والمقابر المألوفة دمرت الجثث المكفنة البارزة
من
التربة وقد استيقظ الموتى من راحتهم الأخيرة